hello good morning and welcome to the
third annual canvas lightning talks my
name is Lucas Wofford I'm the executive
director for digital education at the
Porvoo Center which means that one of
the really most rewarding parts of my
job is that I get to work with the
educational technology team who oversees
the canvas learning management system as
a large part of their work and here
today we will highlight a number of
partnerships that we have with faculty
as well as hear from some of our poor
who Center colleagues about how they use
canvas now when the Porvoo Center first
hosted this event three years ago we
were in the middle of transitioning to
canvas and one of the many reasons why
our community chose canvas as a learning
management system is because it is not a
traditional learning management system
traditional learning management systems
over the years locked you into their
environment they required you to use the
tools that they developed canvas is an
open platform it is a platform that
encourages its educational partners to
use third-party apps that very easily
plug into its environment so that you
can meet the specific teaching and
learning goals for your university and
your faculty now as you can imagine an
open platform we all know we think of
things like the App Store on iTunes
they become vibrant communities that are
continually developing and improving so
what we are going to talk about today is
our goal to partner with instructors all
around the university to identify ways
for educational technology tools to make
the teaching and learning process more
effective today's presentations will
focus on tools that create engaging
accessible and inclusive core sites
through the canvas platform so today we
will hear from natalia cordova sanchez a
lecturer in psychology who will present
on the use of grade scope and a large
lecture class maria Trumpler senior
lecturer in women's studies gender and
sexuality studies she will talk about
the use of named coach Eve's Ucker
a lecturer and anthropology we'll talk
about ereserves through the library
system Michelle Morgan well is our
digital accessibility specialist she
works here in the porvoo Center as well
and as well as an IT s
she will discuss the use of ally and its
role in our accessibility initiatives
and then we'll hear from two of our
colleagues here at the for vous Center
tymberlee Barbara Marini who I believe
many if not all of you know and if you
don't you will by the end of this event
as well as Brian pause they will share
updates on some of the pilots that we
are currently running in canvas and some
of the ideas that we're looking at
toward or for the fall I should say but
first I'd like to introduce Natalia who
will be our first speaker of the day
Natalia thank you for kicking us off
here you to the organizers for giving me
the opportunity to tell you about great
scope tool that Yale is piloting but
first I want to start us off by asking
you some some questions so if you could
go to pole F comm this will work for not
just my presentation but for the other
so you'll be all set follow these
instructions
are we good to go I believe it is
getting a sense yeah there we go
okay so if you could just respond to
these questions basically select all
that apply to you so if you successfully
logged on these should be showing up on
your device and just click on all the
ones that that apply to you and if
you're not in the classroom right now
they've applied in the past maybe and if
you've never been in the classroom maybe
you've heard your colleagues talk about
some of these complain about some of
these and you can continue to respond
but I've gotten enough responses that oh
okay I know how to do this all right
here you go so lots of these apply to
lots of you is what I'm seeing here so I
think that our time together will be
helpful that's what I'm that's what I'm
hoping so first of all what is great
scope great scope as you might be
guessing is something about grading and
it's basically a grading software that
leverages the strengths of computers and
artificial intelligence to streamline a
lot of the grading process what I'm
hoping to convince you of today is that
regardless of your subject matter in
class size there might be benefits to
you we'll see so but just a preview ah
great scope helps the teaching team the
people doing the grading by streamlining
the management portion of grading by
cutting down on grading time
significantly especially for some types
of classes and some assignments helping
you grade consistently and fairly across
students and by getting a better sense
of how the students are engaging with
the assignments I also hope to convince
you that there's benefits to the
students in part as a downstream
consequence of all the benefits for the
teaching team because the students just
for example get quick
feedback and great turnaround which is
huge for learning I keep not using that
so canvas great scope is synced with
canvas it's one of these third-party
apps so once you link your courses with
great on great scope your site might
look something like this
and I'm showing you mine because I want
to highlight the variety of classes in
which I've used great scope so I'm
teaching a class a seminar lab based
class this semester with 14 students and
one teaching fellow but I'm also
teaching this large 400 student class
with nine teaching fellows last semester
I taught a class with five students and
no teaching fellows so it was just me
grading the exams of five students and I
still found great scope to be helpful so
let's see what why why is it so helpful
well let's start with the AI assistant
grading so for some types of assignments
in particular so think multiple choice
or short responses you you can use
artificial intelligence great scope uses
artificial intelligence to group similar
responses basically avoid grading each
question one by one so this is what you
do you upload your assignment template
your blank exam blank
assignment to to grade scope and you
tell them where your questions are so in
this example I have multiple choice
questions so I'm just telling it where
I'm telling great scope I'm telling the
computer where it can find each of the
questions but I do this for all of them
I do all the questions I do this for
Mort response questions to for
multiple-choice questions I can ask it
to group similar responses and so as you
can see here there's gonna be because I
have four options in this multiple
choice example there can be four groups
right at most so as you can see here
three hundred and seventy-five students
chose a response see maybe you can't see
a ten students chose a and so on and so
forth so how do i grade I just mark
each of these responses as being correct
or incorrect and so just with basically
like four clicks I've graded the 400
responses for this particular question
so like I said here is me grading one
instance of this group I mark it as
correct because in this case it was and
like that with the click of a button
I've graded 375 responses I do this for
the other ones too for the other
responses they'll be incorrect and I
it's even better so I just click on the
incorrect one take off the points and I
it's even better if I write there what
the correct response would was because
then the students can see that so that
tool is super powerful and if you have
an assignment that lends itself well to
that that is amazing but even for
questions that you have to grade one by
one
sure responds there's gonna be a variety
of responses it still can be super
helpful
why because you maybe have experience
with this it's better to just grade all
the one question for all the students
back-to-back right but what do you have
to do you have to flip through the pages
and your stack of exams well here your
stock is on this computer you just click
Next ungraded and it shows up and and
the next question for the the next
instance of that same question will show
up on your screen it's really easy to to
divide grading amongst different people
and your teaching team it just won't
show up a question it won't show you a
question that's already been grading
unless graded unless you are
specifically looking for it right so you
can divide up the grading amongst
teaching amongst a teaching team very
very easily so that's really great but
here's another feature so some of you
responded that you find yourself giving
similar feedback to different students
right so here you can kind of build your
your toolkit of response essay so this
is just an example of me grading a
multiple short answer a question and so
say I want to take off some points or
just mention that the student didn't
mention
and concept acts say so I write that
down I say I'll take off half a point
because you you you should have
mentioned blah blah blah right now when
I when I click Next on graded I'm
grading the next students response I can
use that same feedback just click on
that button and as you can see you know
think about it you're you're giving the
same wording to the to the student and
it's just in and it's attached to the
same point value right so this helps
with consistency and fairness across
students and of course you don't have to
repeat yourself over and over again so
give consistent feedback across students
also has it ever happened to you that
you're halfway through the stack of
exams and you change your mind I really
shouldn't have taken off half a point I
really should have taken off a quarter
of a point for example you can change
the point value or the feedback the
wording for one instance and it changes
it for the whole stack that you've
already gone through that's huge in our
case with 400 students has been
incredible once you are done grading
this adds everything up it constructs
that it gives you a huge spreadsheet
with all the statistics that you might
have wanted and more it with a click of
a button you can post the grades to
canvas with another click you can write
an email to students to say their exams
are available and they can go to grade
scope to check them out I've received
zero emails from students saying that
they don't know how to access their
exams so this works also something that
I want to highlight here yeah 400
students I would have received an email
something that I want to highlight to is
the statistics for each question did
everybody get a particular question
right did a lot of people not get a
question right you can get that
information very easily so you can go to
the classroom empowered with this
information about how the students are
engaging with the material which is huge
their customer service team is amazing
they have somebody whose title is
customer happiness and I can attest to
how well she does her job and yeah so if
you have any questions I'll be hanging
out afterward
okay let me know I'll try to convince
you to use great responses yeah yeah
that's me writing that down now maybe
your question is do you have to do that
beforehand you can do it as you go so
depending on what kind of responses you
receive your write your feedback in and
then you can keep your using it yeah
yeah yeah it's different in a lot of
ways so speed grader like the students
are doing this already on the computer
right so it's already there I used that
to a simultaneously so we can talk more
afterwards because I think time's up but
yeah let's talk more about that thank
you